بدايتنا غامضه مع الكثير من التساؤلات
وتنظيرات وراءها الحدث الاكبر هذا الشهر
الا وهو الزلزال نتحدث بالطابعه الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا ولكن ايضا
عن زلزال الاشاعات وتفسيرات والتاويلات
وحتى التوقعات البدايه كانت مع تغريده
العالم الهولندي الذي تنبا بالزلزق قبل
وقوعي بثلاثه ايام تفسير العلماء ذلك بان
الصدفه كانت في صفه العالم او الدجال بحسب
انقسام الناس حوله والمفارقه تنبا بزلزال
ثاني وهذا الزلزال حصل بدوره العالم
الهولندي يقول انه يعتمد على تموضع
الكواكب من اجل توقع الزلازل وهي وسيله
غير معتمده علميا لكن اليوم نتحدث فقط عن
التوقعات بل عن نظريات مؤامره غريبه
ومثيره يبدو ان الكثيرين وكالعاده يميلون
لتصديقها
[موسيقى]